et merci monsieur le commissaire mais il
ya quand même deux ans de travaux on a
eu deux colloques ici ici ou au sénat et
c'est vrai que vous avez un slogan qui
peut séduire en effet c'est notre
réforme sera simple et juste
sauf que quand on déroule la pelote et
quand on regarde certaines mesures est
le dernier exemple en date c'est quand
même celui des retraites des femmes qui
ont eu notamment trois enfants ou plus
et l'institut de la protection sociale
est très clair dessus ça ne tient pas
c'est à dire que vous allez non non je
persiste et signe
les chiffres sont têtus vous allez en
fait sacrifier les familles qui qui
renouvelle les générations alors qu'on a
un système qui est basée justement sur
ces mêmes générations
donc nos objectifs à nous était très
clair c'était en effet revalorisation
des passes des pensions pas de baisse
des retraites réforme des régimes
spéciaux mais sans creuser le déficit et
sans laisser filer le déficit et c'est
là où il ya une différence
alors pour l'instant vous essayez de
gagner du temps parce que vous êtes
tenus par votre promesse de ne pas faire
de réformes paramétriques mais pour
l'instant vous gagnez du temps et désolé
de vous décevoir mais c'est toujours
aussi floue pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]